[Music]
it has been nearly three years since Kim
Davis a County Clerk in rural Kentucky
caused a nationwide uproar when she
refused to sign gay marriage licenses
because of her religious beliefs the
move made her a household name at a
galvanizing figure in the debate over
same-sex marriage this week
correspondent Matt Finn updates us on
whatever happened to Kim Davis tucked
away in the rolling hills of Morehead
Kentucky today Kim Davis is back to her
routine somewhat quiet daily life as the
Rowan County Clerk back in 2015
shortly after a landmark Supreme Court
case made gay marriage legal Davis
became a target for some and an icon to
others when she refused to issue
same-sex marriage licenses arguing it
violated her Christian beliefs my face
my life my past was smashed everywhere
not just here not just in our country
but all over the place all over the
world under her Authority our United for
others it began when a same-sex couple
recorded this video of Davis refusing to
issue their marriage license the video
went viral death threats
Davis denied budge and ended up in jail
for contempt of court
[Music]
Davis was released after five days into
the arms of then presidential candidate
Arkansas governor Mike Huckabee I never
envisioned anything like this you know I
had in my mind I was going to retire
with my mother and I was going to live
an easy life and that's what I wanted to
do but you know the Lord had something
else in store for me
because of Davis Kentucky marriage
licenses were eventually altered so that
County Clerk's don't have to sign them
the mother of three recently wrote a
book about her experience and is now
running for re-election and in November
the person she may face is none other
than David ermold people are cruel to do
this to us one of the men in that viral
video you can take a stand and you can
still have compassion and you can have
her step and that is what we're gonna do
we're gonna change the face of politics
in Kentucky David ermold returned to the
county clerk's office but this time
davis processed his application to run
for office Davis says she has no regrets
if I could go back and be given this
chance all over again I would not worry
about we didn't exactly in the name of
standing up for what she believes in Kim
Davis went to jail and ended up keeping
her job now one of the Democratic
candidates trying to take it from her is
getting offers of help from Hollywood
and once again shining the national
spotlight here on Morehead Kentucky Matt
fin Fox News